what even is mincemeat and why do we
want to put it in the pie I'm hope it's
not liver
it's made of mints I have no idea oh boy
this has some nice weight to it the
crust looks nicely done I like the
little sugar sprinkles on the top it has
three holes in the top you know how to
get it out the container we don't want
to litter up our whiskers with a bunch
of pie crust first time ever you know
that's interesting
the crust is dead chewy tasty but it's
dry the top of the question is very
crumbly very good reasons and I'm not
sure some cinnamon I'm enjoying the
taste and the sensation and the texture
you know tastes a little bit real raisin
but you need something to drink with
this maybe some hot chocolate or some
hot tea what the heck that reminds me
the Thanksgiving pie that my mother used
to make years and years ago I would
revisit these this is a treat that we
have to teach more American households
but I think this was an excellent pie
don't look at something to say ooh Nick
I don't like it try it
very good very well so if you think
they've put out something for Santa a
little mince pie thank you